i wonder how
would my grandfather feel if he saw what
i did to his business today
my grandfather might be angry because he
is very strict
when he was running ching you hing in
the beginning
when my grandfather started we actually
started with making
your chinese candies your sansa
the hot on in the 40s 50s we started
making
rock sugar red sugar and black jaggery
sugar which we still do
till today when i came into the business
it was really about
trying to look at processes uh trying to
modernize the business
and eventually led to creating our own
brand of
jewels rock sugar sticks which was a
reinvention
of our traditional rock sugar
for chiang king we kind of like were
like a
one one hit wonder kind of product the
market at that time
a lot of the younger generation didn't
know how to use your sugar
if i were to rate the difficulty in
transforming the business
i guess it would be 10 out of 10 or 11
out of 10.
the process was difficult trying to
change a very traditional
business at the start when i first
joined the business
almost 12 years ago for me when i took
over the business
my family was telling me why change it
when it's not broken is that kind of
fear that you
think about you know whether what you do
has any
success or failure and then telling them
to do something that they were not
accustomed to took a lot of
energy a lot of time but you know you do
it step by step and then
gain that trust and kind of respect
and then you can do a lot more as well
in 2014 we went for first exhibition
almost in the whole history of our
company we took part in
food hotel asia and we we just wanted to
you know just showcase our products
and and look for international
businesses
new markets and when we exhibited many
of our old customers were like so why
are you here
you know you have like no new products
uh we know all your products
so that kind of got me started and
thinking
there's something that we really need to
do i first
learned about design thinking when i
went to san francisco
on a business learning trip we actually
had workshops on design thinking
learning about
different personas how customer-centric
design thinking was and in fact some of
the takeaways that i learned during this
trip was how to
spot trends look at design as a focus
design thinking was something that
actually
set you apart from the rest of the
competitors as well is
not just the end result it's also the
process
to reach out to the younger audiences
first we need to understand
how they think what they want so
obviously they wanted something more
you know social media friendly you know
instagrammable
something more experiential that they
will be able to connect with the brand
when i was creating the packaging with
our designer there were a lot of
reiterations there were a lot back and
forth as well
i remember occasions where i was working
with the flavour houses
tasting different rock sugar sticks in
different intensities in different
flavors
and so we came out with the jewel rock
sugar sticks
which has color flavor packaging
but also the way you have it like a
candy
or dipping candy was what set us apart
from
what was out there in the market
in our traditional rock sugar the top
layer of the rock sugar very pretty very
you know shiny so a lot of our customers
would call it two or post so naturally
when we had to think of a name
to name our rock sugar sticks then we
thought what do we have existingly
that you know connects with our
consumers or our market
and then you know since we already had
pulse
maybe we can call it jewels and that
would also
be able to target the younger generation
the ones that we wanted
them to you know feel that all our rock
sugar sticks
are as precious as them
[Music]
so with jewels actually it helped us
open a lot
new uh possibilities and some of that
was
opportunities being sold in china
then in hong kong and then malaysia and
then
of course in singapore it gave us new
markets
but at the same time gave us
opportunities to work with different
brands
so we when we first started we had the
opportunity to
work with the 1872 clipper t company
together we created a
tea set that had tea as well as rock
sugar sticks
that you could pair differently you can
gift
or you could you know just enjoy and
consume it on your own
so it will not only open new overseas
markets
it also opened new consumers to our
business
and that's what we really wanted so in
2018
we went into the business of food
incubation with innovate 360.
from zero startups now we have about 28
startups in different verticals from
food sustainability agritech deep tech
as well as
consumer package products these are the
startups that we foresee can disrupt the
future
we wanted to tap on the startups to
create products that could sell through
our channels
so this is like an entire contrasting
part
from what i first started in the
business looking at
you know your iso processors so a lot of
all these has actually resulted from the
fact that
you know how we approach our business
how we look at it differently
design thinking has helped us develop
new business lines
but also create opportunities for us
to collaborate with people and to
influence them
in creating design-centric products or
even processes
if my grandfather was still alive
he would definitely be scolding me and
saying wow what are you doing
you see me see jewels uh what have you
done to the business
because he was a very strict person so i
think
he would be mad but
i think he will also be proud in the
sense that we've come full circle
from his time of creating your chinese
candies
to going back to making jewels and then
at the same time leveraging from
you know create all these sugar and
candies to creating
a lot of impact to the world right now i
think that that's something
that he would be proud of at the same
time
leaving a legacy that the next
generation will be able to
take over
[Music]
you